the iron men as they're called or the
ironborn as they call themselves
are a little different from the people
of the mainland
uh in some ways i guess they're they're
similar to uh
to vikings in real life history
um but there are some differences there
too uh the
the iron islands are not tremendously
fertile um
so the the people who live there have a
very hard scrabble existence
allen is one of these uh men who
who shares the dream of the more
conservative and traditional
ironborn to return to the old ways to
become an independent king
um and
therefore he rose in rebellion
a number of years ago after robert had
taken the iron throne
and and thrown down the targaryens
um he thought he saw an opportunity
there well is this new dynasty going to
be as strong as the targaryens
doesn't have the loyalty maybe this is a
good opportunity if robert can take over
the
the seven kingdoms this is a good chance
to break away
so he he raised his own standard
declared himself king and that was
ballen greyjoy's rebellion
uh which ultimately was put down
by a combination of the baratheons and
the starks
you know the greyjoy's slogan is we do
not sow
uh which basically means we're we're
reapers
you can sew you can plant the grain
we'll come and take it when it's ready
uh you can you know mine the gold
we'll come and take it eventually we do
not so we we just come and take
it's certainly not easy but yes the
night's watch takes no part that's been
that tradition for thousands of years
the night's watch the wall was built to
protect
the realms but you have to remember how
old the wall is i mean by tradition it's
like 8
000 years old you know the seven
kingdoms have only been one kingdom
for 300 years since aegon's conquest
so for thousands of years before that
you you had seven separate kingdoms or
ten separate kingdoms or fourteen
separate kingdoms or
if you go far enough back you had a
hundred kingdoms all little pocket-sized
kingdoms all of them warring against the
next kingdom
but they all had one common
enemy which is
whatever force north of the wall
so you're creating a large armed force
on the northern border
but you don't want that armed force
interfering in your own wars you know
when
when the lannisters are fighting the the
gardeners or or the uh
the dornish men are invading the
stormlands or
the riverlords and the iron men are
fighting uh
then you're just creating another
lordship so it became
you know that taking the black was for
life and that the night's watch
takes no part they are they are neutral
their their eyes are
fixed on the north fixed beyond the wall
the fist of the first men is an old ring
fort the first men of course were the
first human beings on westeros predating
the andals and the rhoynar
and uh the valerians who who came in
successive waves in later millennia
but it's called that because it looks
like a fist coming up
with the with the stones like knuckles
around that around the top of it
thrusting up out of the ground
the only hill for a long way around but
mormont
uh halts the ranging there it's a it's a
well-recognized
landmark in the north that rangers have
used it's defensible because of this
ring of ancient stones
should any wildlings attack and of
course what they're looking for
is number one what's happening to the
wildlings and
what about the others and the white
walkers and all these
these rumors and tales that are drifting
but also what is
what does the king be on the wall up to
where is mance raider the king beyond
the wall
and uh that's what they're aiming to
find but they they halt at the fist of
the first men and sort of make their
northern expeditionary camp there uh
while they
explore that and send out scouts to try
to find out more about some of these
things
cersei is trying to protect joffrey and
she's
trying to protect all her children
and she's also trying to rule
but cersei was never trained to rule i
mean
again because of her sex um
some some lords
are more accepting
of the possibility of a female heir
but lord tywin was very much a
traditionalist and never never looked at
cersei that way he just looked at her as
a
as a game piece and uh you know he would
make the most advantageous marriage
for her that he could that would advance
the cause of house lannister
and his own personal power and
strengthen them but
he'd certainly never looked at a cersei
as someone who would have to rule
now as as regent as the king's mother
um she has great power but it's all
it's all new to her and she's also i
think she's also
reacting to years of being excluded and
you know pushed aside um
kept from power so there's a certain
paranoia there that uh
people will try to do that to her again
and she doesn't react well to being
challenged or being defied